hello everybody I'm finally back from
Michigan in case some of you people
didn't notice her weren't following on
Facebook or Twitter I was up in Michigan
for three days visiting MSU with my
friend of mine and he had some
engineering conference so I decided to
tailgate with him and we went up there
had a good time but I am now back and
videos will be rolling out shortly a few
things to cover um we hit a hundred and
twenty five thousand subscribers
yesterday which i'm i feel bad about
because i wasn't even here for what had
happened but things have been happening
so quickly that i can't keep up with it
anymore i mean by the time you watch
this video i'll already be at a hundred
and twenty seven thousand i think so
things that have just been going
absolutely crazy i've been averaging
about fifteen hundred subscribers a day
and that's absolutely a mind-blowing
number if you think back those of you
who have been with me for a long time if
you think back like I was happy just to
get a thousand subscribers I was happy
to get a hundred subscribers at the time
and it was it was it was just a totally
different atmosphere from then than now
so I'm so happy that you guys have been
joining me and feeling like my content
is good enough to share because I really
do appreciate every subscriber and I I
mean I never want to people to think
that I don't because just because I
don't celebrate it every single thousand
I just can't anymore because that
happens everyday and I wish I could
thank you personally but I unfortunately
can that's this that's a problem that
happens when you get more subscribers
like this so just thank you guys so much
know that from the bottom of my heart I
wouldn't have been on the news if it
weren't for you guys and that was like
an incredible opportunity and they've
been I've been like interviewed by radio
stations who just want to hear like what
I've been doing and have no idea what it
is to be a youtuber who plays video
games and can raise charity they're like
marveled at this so they keep asking me
like how does this even work how do they
trust you and stuff like that and I I
have to admit that the only reason that
it does work is because I I try to
connect as much as possible with you
guys I try to show you guys that I'm
honest and I'm honest and everything I
do so you guys trusting me is a big part
of that I'm so grateful that you do so
thank you everybody so much it's just
it's mind-blowing I don't have time to
keep up with any more because it was
really two weeks ago we just hit a
hundred thousand subscribers and we're
already passing the quarter of the way
to two hundred thousand we should be at
two hundred thousand like two months
at this rate so it's just absolutely
incredible I couldn't be happier with
what's going on so I'm going to try to
make better videos everyday I'm gonna
try to entertain you guys I'm never
gonna slow down so thank you guys truly
and honestly from the bottom of my heart
and I'll try not to take too many
vacations but my friends um I end a
little Las Vegas trip while we were up
in MSU or actually before then actually
but it the plan has been solidified so
I'm going to Vegas sometime in the
summer so thank you all so much for
watching I'm happy that I can just do
this you guys have given me so many
awesome opportunities both to help and
just for myself it's totally changed my
life and the outlook that I'm doing and
what I'm doing with my life and how I'm
trying to help people so thank you guys
so much for everything you guys are
literally the best fans in the world I
couldn't ask for like anything more from
you guys so thank you again and thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye